Depuis ma vidéo sur Senna,  plus aucune star de télé-réalité s'est remis à la chanson,
ça c'est ...
ou pas
Dingue, dingue de toi... Nabi...Nabilla
Sofiane, ancien candidat de télé-réalité, sort une chanson pour déclarer sa flamme à Nabilla, ancienne candidate de télé-réalité.
Et Sofiane a totalement craqué pour Débilla
euh ...
Nabilla, pardon !
Ça, ça crève les yeux, hein !
à peine arrivé à destination, j'aimais déjà ton délire et tes façons...
*J'aimais déjà ton délire et tes façons.*
Euh ...
Ah! ah d'accord !
Ah oui !
C'est comme ça qu'il les appelle ok d'accord : *délire et façon*.
Je... je comprends mieux ! Tout est plus clair d'un coup c'est...
Déjà, rien qu'en lisant la description de la vidéo on est euh... Désappointé, hein ?
*Le clip de "l'énorme" tube de Sofiane*.
L'homme le plus modeste du monde quoi hein!
Parce que *énorme*, ok
tube, euh non.
J'aurais plutôt dit une énorme
*bruits de dhiarrée*
Et apparemment, la crise est passée par là, il n'y avait plus assez de budget pour acheter du tissu.
tu joue avec le feu
Il y a tellement peu de tissu sur Nabilla que la vidéo est passée en interdit au moins de 18 ans sur YouTube.
C'est la crise ! C'est la crise !
2ème restriction budgétaire, vous avez vu où ils ont tourné le refrain.
dingue, dingue, dingue, dingue, dingue, dingue de toi...  Nabi... Nabilla
Sous la douche.
Euh... Ouais.
C'est la crise !
Mais, pourquoi pas hein, enfin cela dit il m'aurait dit de faire le clip, je serai même allé encore plus loin.
*Dingue dingue de toi Nabi-Nabilla j'euh*
T'est sûr pour le rideau ?
C'est... C'est peut être un peu trop?
- Non non non, t'inquiète.
*Bon bah... Je suis fou de toi Nabi-Nabilla*
Attendez, il faut écouter les paroles aussi, c'est exceptionnel,
J'ais... J'ais jamais entendu ça de ma vie !
quand j'ai maté ce boule qui valait de l'or
monté comme un piston... j'suis en pôle, pôle, pôle, position
*Monté comme un piston* ?
Monté comme un piston, c'est... bon déjà, paye ta modéstie!
Et ensuite il espère séduire une fille en disant ça !
Exceptionnel !
- Tu sais Debilla, quand je pense a toi je...
- Non ! Non ! Non!
- Calme toi ! Calme toi!
- Excuse moi.
- C'est  parce que j'ai un très gros piston.
- Donc je disais je...
- Non ! Non ! Non ! Non!
- Calme toi !
- Voila !
- C'est des choses qui arrivent
Et surtout, grande première dans la chanson, Sofiane le premier chanteur bègue.
des courbes qui pourrait, pourrait faire changer, changer un gay de bord
j'avoue ton body, body met des frissons
trop, trop, trop tard je suis déjà sous pression
je suis en pôle, pôle, pôle, position
Un chanteur bègue.
Narmol!
- T'es... T'es... T'es sur que je peux ch... ch... ch... chanter, ça va p... p... p... pas dé... dé... déranger ?
- Non t'inquiète pas dis : Nabilla, pour voir ?
- Nabi...Nabilla
- Nabilla.
- Bon, ok fais comme tu le sens.
- Ok je suis en pôle...pôle...pôle position
Et j'aimerais terminer en disant que je respecte Nabilla pour sa patience, moi ça me soulerait qu'on écorche mon nom pendant 4 minutes non-stop.
- Nabi... Nabilla
- Non c'est juste, juste Nabilla.
-Nabi...Nabilla
- C'est pas Nabi... Nabilla, c'est juste Nabilla.
-Nabi... Nabilla
- Pourquoi tu mets Nabi au début ? Nabilla.
- Est-ce que je dis Sofi... sofiane ?
-Nabi... Nabilla
- Non ! Juste Nabilla.
- Oh arrête ! arrête ! arrête! arrête!
-Nabi... Nabilla
- Tu rajoutes encore un Nabi, je te pète la gueule.
Chaque fois que vous partagez cette vidéo, Nabilla se fait refaire une partie de son corps.
On verra combien de temps il faudra avant qu'elle se transforme en plastique.
Une minute ou deux.
Pas euh...
Sous-titres: MDR lol
Si tu veux voir mes autres vidé... vidéo  Va sur Cyprien.FR... FR  Oui d'accord je ne sais pas chanter mais c'est pas grave.